[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists when we get past
the material clutter we often find boxes
and bins of emotional clutter buried
deep in our hearts and minds
no matter how intelligent or creative
someone is or what type of personality
they have it is how they navigate their
inner world their thoughts feelings and
self-talk that ultimately determines how
peaceful and joyous they will become
today on this public minimal episode
we're speaking with renowned
psychologist dr susan david about
decluttering emotional clutter then this
thursday on the minimalist private
podcast susan and the minimalists will
answer a bunch more listener questions
about getting unstuck and we'll discuss
the four essential movements to become
emotionally agile you can check that
maximal episode at patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck our first question
today is from sabrina on patreon
what does good emotional health look
like and what's the best way to achieve
it
you know
susan so in your book they're on page 59
you talk about the good news about bad
moods
and so i want to talk about this and we
were talking about it a bit on the
maximal episode which we already
recorded how unfortunately we moralize
everything happiness is good and sadness
is bad
and anger is bad but bliss is good and
what you've done especially with this
book i'll hold it up here it's called
emotional agility
and what you've done in the book is
you've helped separate that moralizing
of every emotion because it's not merely
about experiencing only the pleasurable
emotions the good emotions and then
shunning the bad emotions we in fact we
had a question about grief and how grief
can be loving and beautiful and
necessary yeah
and yet we're often just looking for
the good in fact it's even in this
question what does good emotional health
look like and i'm reminded of a mystic i
heard someone asked him if he gets angry
he said it's not that i'm not capable of
anger
but i don't give anyone the privilege of
making me angry
and it was uh
this morning ryan said something and he
was like are you am i frustrating you
and i was like you don't have the power
to frustrate me only i have the power to
frustrate me only i have the power to
make me angry only i have the power to
make myself upset now of course our
environment affects us in different ways
but generally it has to do with the
expectations we set and then when the
environment doesn't comport with our
expectations that's when we feel those
negative emotions yeah
there's this beautiful um quote which is
expectations or disappointments waiting
to happen
i love it i love it yes
i actually don't know who's that's not
mine i don't know who it's from but but
i i spoke about about a bit in the book
um
yeah i mean the the traditional way of
dealing with and it connects with this
question our emotions is that they're
good or bad positive or negative
um and this is a rigid view that is not
uh
true
to the reality of our experience i mean
charles darwin described how our
difficulty like it tells no one
described how all of our emotions all of
our emotions help us to communicate with
ourselves what are my needs what do i
care about what are my values and others
what are their needs what are their
values and so on
and so a really important part of
emotional health is moving away from
hustling with whether you are or aren't
allowed to feel something
and instead
facing into the fact that you do feel
that in in emotional agility i talk
about how
acceptance
is the prerequisite to change and it's
this remarkable paradox that we have in
our own lives it's it's like only when
you accept
face into the reality of what is
that you can move forward into what
could be and when i say acceptance i
don't mean passive resignation i don't
mean like oh my goodness you know i'm
sad now i don't feel like getting out of
bed and there's nothing i can do there
if i'm going to stay but you know i
don't mean passive resignation i mean
acceptance of what is you know only when
we
face into
a world in which people are unseen and
we accept and recognize that we can
actually start changing it only when we
accept that climate change is a fact and
we recognize that reality will always
have its way
that we
are able to change that and so you know
you speak about anger um i'm reminded
my south african accent so so i grew up
as a white child
in the white suburbs of apartheid south
africa
and it was very much a country and a
community committed uh
to not seeing to not seeing other
people's pain to not seeing and to
denial
and
i
found so
remarkable in that context the
words of nelson mandela you know nelson
mandela
had a
remarkable relationship with his anger
and what he described is how
firstly his anger
helped him to connect with what he cared
about
so i would actually suggest that anger
is a very very important emotion there
is no
change that has ever happened
in our communities or in our society
without anger yeah okay
so anger is crucial but one of the
things that charles darwin uh so
told darwin one of the things that
mandela described is how
it was the
recognition
of his anger and what his anger was
signposting about his values
that then
in his words
enabled him to sit down with his
oppressors
and i think this is remarkable and it's
worth giving pause to because a core
part of my work is the idea that
emotions are data
emotions are data emotions tell us what
we care about
but emotions are not
directives
all right and this is really important
just because i feel angry doesn't mean i
get to have it out with anyone doesn't
mean i get to act with impunity
so it's almost like if we can kind of
step into our emotions and we can say
what are the data that these emotions
are signposting what what is being
threatened here what value that's
important to me is being threatened
so we can use those data
but we aren't
letting them be directives we are
instead of
letting that anger hold us we are
instead stepping into our values
so they the emotions are data they're
not directives what are the directives
our values our wisdom and and this is so
important because often when we get
hooked when we see on twitter or when
people get really you know upset about
something and it's like they're upset
because their values have been
contravened
but they're operating
out of their rage
rather than into their values yes and
when you operate out of your rage you
actually
are very often going against your values
that's right you know you often are now
breaking down communication
and so i love this notion from nelson
mandela because it was this idea of
i'm not turning away from my anger
i'm learning from my anger and it's the
learning about my values that allows me
to then have the conversations that i
need to have in order to create change
oh that's beautiful
because
the emotions in a way and i wrote this
down as we were preparing for this
episode emotions are like children you
can love them without letting them run
the show
yes i i emotions of data not directives
i can show up to my son's frustration
with his baby sister my son's more
introverted and he needs his space and
his baby sister loves climbing on his
head while he's reading i can show up to
my son's frustration with his baby
sister i can see it i can summon it you
know i see you and by seeing how
bringing into being i can do all of
those things
it doesn't mean i'm endorsing his idea
that he gets to give her way to the
first stranger he sees in a shopping
mall that's right we own our emotions
they don't own us
yeah and so when i say that emotions are
like children you can love them
but they don't get to run the show i
have a nine-year-old daughter i love her
and i can see her
but i don't have to let her tug me
around with every impulse that she might
have and so in a way our emotions
they create these impulses to act
angrily to act against our values yay
and they put me in a situation where i'm
often going to regret what i do but i
can see the emotion for what it is i can
experience the emotion whether it's
being upset or elated or any sort of
emotion in between and i can see that i
can even appreciate it without it being
the the director of the show yeah i'm
i'm reminded you know by this question
of uh and it it connects also just with
this idea of emotional health i'm
reminded so much of um you know that
beautiful victor frankl sentiment that
i'm sure you've discussed previously on
the show this idea that
i think it's probably one of the most
profoundly powerful ideas in human
history which is viktor frankl survived
the nazi death camps
and he describes this idea that between
stimulus and response there is a space
and in that space is our power to choose
and it's in that choice that lies our
growth and our freedom
so now
what does emotional
ill health look like or when we when we
not being healthy with our emotions
there's no space between stimulus and
response so what do i mean what i mean
here
i mean either that we're acting out of
autopilot we buying things we don't need
we automatically when our husband starts
on the finances we leave the room we
stress so we bring our cell phone to the
table like there's there's a there's no
space between stimulus and response so
that's one way of having no space the
other way of having no space is um
the the the psychological term is fusion
or in in my book i talk about being
hooked
and what do i mean by this um
our
difficult emotions and stories like we
have around sixteen thousand spoken
thoughts every single day
sixteen thousand wow and many more
thousand course through our minds so
what starts happening is we've got these
normal this normal stream of thoughts
and emotions that are helping us
find our way in the world and make sense
of the world
what starts to happen sometimes is we
start getting hooked by a thought or an
emotion or fused with it that their
synonyms that they're the same thing
hooked or fused and really what we're
doing in this context is we are
over identifying with the thought of the
emotion there's no space for anything
else so here's what i mean
when you say something like
i am not good enough
what you've done is you've taken a
thought
i'm having the thought that i'm not good
enough and you've now turned it into a
fact and into a prison yeah okay
into a prison that's now directing your
action there's no space between stimulus
and response
so one of the most powerful ways that we
can start developing emotional agility
is to create space between stimulus and
response and the first way we do this is
by stopping to hustle with our difficult
emotions like stop trying to
allow you decide whether you're allowed
or not allowed to feel something you're
feeling what you're feeling so showing
up to that emotion with compassion and
acceptance is powerful
uh we spoke in the maximalist episode
about granularity about being you know
more granular about your emotions
instead of just saying
i'm stressed actually trying to get
deeper like is it stress or is it
disappointment or is it sadness
when we are more granular with our
emotions
you can see like if you stressed
then you kind of fused your body your
psychology doesn't know what to do with
it you just like stuck
but if you start saying
actually this thing i'm calling stress
is actually i feel unsupported
as you start labeling
unsupported
there is this remarkable thing that
happens psychologically which is you
start understanding the cause of that
emotion
and also what you need to be doing in
relation to it even as i use the word
unsupported it's like
why am i supported and how can i get
support
and so when we become granular with our
emotions it actually starts to activate
what scientists call the readiness
potential in our brains the parts of our
brains that help us to
not be held hostage by the difficult
emotion but to rather step into our
values
so that's the second thing and then
another thing that's really important
that we haven't touched on yet in terms
of emotional health
is to
not
over identify with the emotion in other
words we create space between stimulus
and response
by recognizing that we aren't our
emotion we aren't our thought so i'll
play this out for you
if i said to you
to you josh like
oh so you are
a person you a business owner you're an
entrepreneur you're a father
you're a child
it's like yes of course i'm all of those
things okay that doesn't feel foreign to
you like you are all of those things all
at once sure
but when we say i am sad
often what we're doing is we are saying
i am all of me is said and there's no
space for anything else we literally
defining ourselves by that singular
emotion
and so what starts to happen is it's
almost like
so this is fusion this is what fusion
actually is it's almost like the emotion
is a cloud a cloud
and you have become the cloud okay i am
sad all of me there's no space for
anything else there's no space for
wisdom values intention breathing
compassion connection there's no space
for anything else
so a really powerful way that we can
start creating the space is by
by
noticing and labeling your thoughts
emotions and stories for what they are
they are thoughts emotions and stories
they are not fact they're beautiful we
can honor them but they are not fact so
what i mean
i
i am sad
that's fusion
i'm noticing that i'm feeling sad what
you're starting to do here is
you're using language to create space
between you and the feeling
i am not good enough
okay that's fusion
[Music]
i'm noticing the thought that i'm not
good enough
okay yeah
i'm noticing the urge
to buy that thing that i don't need
so what starts to happen is when we
start noticing our thoughts our emotions
and our stories for what they are which
is thoughts emotions and stories
we start creating the victor frankl
critical space between stimulus and
response
so we start recognizing actually
here's the beauty which is we are not
the cloud
in fact we are the sky
you know we are the sky
we are beautiful and capacious
and
human enough to experience all of our
difficult emotions and thoughts
and not be owned by them
yeah that's great it makes the whole
cliche of stopping and counting to 10
take on an actual meaning for me because
it gives i mean i'm not recommending
that per say although maybe i am
recommending it but
you know when you stop and count to 10
it gives you time to kind of process the
emotion rather than act on it and you
also talked about in the maximal like
hugging yourself yeah i feel like that's
a great way to pause as well if when
you're having a really negative emotion
often when i'm doing talks for
organizations people say things to me
like well you know our teams are going
through a gazillion zoom calls every day
how do we help them to develop a better
sense of connection and i'm like a
better sense of connection starts before
you go on the zoom
you know it goes in like actually
grounding yourself and and this becomes
really important you you when people
think about emotions often they say well
you know i my emotions catch me of god
and so
you know i'm struggling to manage my
emotions effectively because they catch
me off god but actually when you when
you
look at it what you start recognizing is
it's not of god at all it's very patent
you know we've been having the same
argument with our spouse for the past 15
years
it's it's like not of god
and so doing this thing which is the
power in the pores
and it is the power and the pause what
it's starting to do is you starting to
say you know i'm being undermined
i'm noticing the thought that i'm being
undermined
you're not avoiding you're not pushing
aside
you're not getting stuck but rather i'm
noticing this thought and you starting
to create a little bit of breathing room
for yourself making some space for yeah
yeah alabama i'm going to apologize to
christy we're running out of time
christie in belle fountain ohio we will
get to her voicemail on a future episode
she called in left a very thoughtful
question but ryan what what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round this is where we
answer oh my goodness our readers text
messages they can text us directly josh
and i uh they can just text 937-202
send in your questions send in your
comments send in your smart remarks so
susan what we do during the lightning
round is we try to share a little pithy
response we call them minimal maxims
podcast john tweezes them out he puts
them in the show notes so people can
amazing this is your long-winded way of
saying don't be long-winded
by the way you can find all of our
minimum actions now at
social minimalmaxims.com heym alabama
looks like kim has a question for us
lately it's been really loud inside my
head and i can't stop worrying over
things i have no control over
any tips for how to snap out of it so i
can get back to daily life
yeah when it's loud inside your head
that is often we starting to brood we're
starting to ruminate and so a very very
important way of starting to move beyond
that
is this labeling like what is what is
this thought what is the worry and like
what is it signposting around what i
care about and how can i move towards
that that becomes one of the most
powerful ways as soon as we start trying
to push thoughts aside there is what we
call an amplification effect and
amplification is if you've ever tried
not to think of a piece of chocolate
cake
we know all we do is think of the
chocolate cake so when we try to push
difficult thoughts aside they actually
come back stronger so it's important to
pause and to
label and try understand
what is
what is the light that's being shown for
me about what i care about
and i think also important there
recognizing you know
what what can't you control becomes
really critical
yeah i have something pithy from susan
from her book actually so the book is
called emotional
yes
you talk about self-compassion a lot in
the book yeah and one thing that i
tweezed out was self-compassion is not
about lying to yourself
yeah
those of us who struggle with
self-compassion we all often think well
i i'm telling myself some sort of false
story i'm lying to myself uh and instead
of being compassionate yeah one of the
great myths of self-compassion is that
it's about lying to yourself that it's
about being weak or that you're being
lazy or you're letting yourself off the
hook and actually the the research shows
you could not be further from the truth
that when you are self-compassionate
when you've got your own back
actually
people who are self-compassionate are
more honest with themselves
have have um
stronger expectations of themselves
are more likely to go for what matters
in their lives because they know that if
and when things don't work out they'll
have their own backs
so it's one of these paradoxes where
sometimes being self-compassionate feels
like
it's
being weak
and yet self-compassionate is actually
what gives us inner strength yeah here's
a pithy thought about worry i wrote this
down as a minimal maxim to worry is to
punish yourself for something that
hasn't even happened yet
and so quite often we are telling
ourselves some story about some
catastrophe you know we catastrophize
this we turn the the mountain the
molehill into a mouth yeah right and as
we do that we worry about something
we're punishing ourself right now in
this moment yeah for something that
hasn't happened may never happen yeah
it's not to say that worry isn't useful
but also it can compound and create
something that doesn't exist at all
absolutely absolutely and and i think
that this is one of those things of like
connecting with
connecting with what matters to you like
if you if you're taking on a project and
that project has a level of risk to it
and we have like a whole lot of worry
about the project
um
what that worry is actually signaling is
that there is this goal there is this
thing that matters to me there's this
thing that's purposeful to me that i
want to move towards and i think if we
can
hold on to the purpose of what we're
doing we are more likely to feel free
it's the difference between you know a
have two goal and a one-to-two goal a
have to goal is like i have to do the
thing i have to present in this way i
have to be liked i have to and we start
getting worried about whether we're
gonna succeed in that particular thing a
one-two goal is where we connect with
our values where we say
fairness is really important to me
so
so how do i
in this conversation that i'm worried
about
how do i have it fairly you know how
fair is it if i don't have this and so
we're bringing our our values much more
front and center to
um what we're doing in a way that's very
liberating yeah yeah so uh josh he
helped me come up with this pithy saying
this morning
the calm is waiting beneath the chaos
and you know i've got a second one to
kind of go along with it i was talking
to a friend this morning and we were
having a conversation about this podcast
and i was talking to him about how my
whole life had been working with my
emotions and how excited i was to like
be with you to like really yeah it's
really um kind of even process them even
more um but he said during our
conversation he said there's no way out
but from within
there's no way out but from within yeah
his name is his name is um osiris shea i
told him i quote him because it's
absolutely beautiful but it's such a
beautiful saying of you know we have to
look inside and find those we have to
find a way to find those pauses because
again beneath that chaos there does lies
some silence yeah
we we live in a world that tells us that
we can fix everything you know if we
don't like our cell phone we can buy a
new cell phone and if we don't like our
house we can repaint it
um and
often what we try to do is we try to fix
our difficult experiences um
with
uh
forced false positivity like just trying
to be positive just pretending that
things are okay
um but in truth there is no way out but
from within from within yeah and um the
within
shapes the outward
in such beautiful ways yeah absolutely
and then i we're talking about guilt and
shame and i just had this pop into my
head and maybe this is lame so you can
uh
yeah on the maximum we did but but kind
of what you were talking about with
pausing you were kind of helping people
move from from shame to guilt so uh
shame is lame guilt can build
[Laughter]
don't tweet that podcast sean
all right um alabama we got a lot more
to talk about but first what do you got
for us here are some voicemail comments
and insights from our listeners
hi this is ansen feller i'm calling from
salt lake city utah i'm a designer and
frequently helped clients navigate
through the process of creating an
intentional home
and in this process i avoided trends at
all costs
and if we really look at what trendy
design is
we see that it's designed to encourage
consumerism
companies are motivated to make products
that will eventually go out of style
so i direct clients to architectural and
design history to inform the style of
the home
quality is just as important in function
as it is in design
hi this is tracy from madison wisconsin
and i wanted to share that over the last
maybe six weeks to two months my
relationship with social media has
drastically changed because my intention
with it has really changed um
mainly i'm a kidney donor and i started
really speaking up about it and trying
to educate people and becoming a
resource for people who are curious
about it because there's so few out
there because this happens but almost
nobody talks about it and it's been so
rewarding and that almost well every
week a new person or even more than one
person will contact me about donation
and it is the most rewarding way i have
used social media i also talk about
finances which is actually spurred from
the budget podcast by the minimalist and
i have gone like hellbent on paying off
debt not using credit cards and i now
have this ripple effect in my social
network of other people that are doing
the same thing so it feels good to be
intentionally spreading the good and
sharing the things most people don't
talk about and seeing really positive
results and even richer and more
positive connections coming back from
that all right y'all before we get to
our right here right now segment and our
added value segment big thanks to dr
susan david here's her book yeah it's
called emotional agility we dive deep
into the book on the maximal episode
over on patreon this week but real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists you may know that a few
years ago i think it was back in 2016
ryan we
we teamed up with carl over at
minimalissimo
and albert over at five style to create
something called minimalism life yeah
and it's a side project of ours that
we've been working on to curate the best
in minimalist travel that's five style
and
and i mean he is
unbelievable aesthetically and carl as
well carl has inspired me from day one
yeah he's he's i got to meet him in
person when i was in edinburgh and yeah
he's a wonderful man he's awesome and so
we teamed up with them to create
minimalism life
the best of minimalist travel
well-being that's the minimalists and
minimalist design that's middle
melissimo
and so
recently
we acquired
minimalism.com
as the domain for minimalism life and so
if you want some articles some design
some wallpaper everything minimalism you
can head on over now to
minimalism.com and you can find that
website there and bathe in the
simplicity bathing minimalism so do we
need to get minimalism.net now
we need more minimalism
you can also follow minimalism life on
twitter at minimalism we had a kind
person gift us that handle they were
sitting on it for a while or uh follow
the beautiful photos and videos reels
over on instagram or tick tock we'll put
links to all of that in the show notes
as well when i'm scrolling on instagram
i'll see like an amazing like very
thoughtful photo i'm like oh who is this
i'm like oh this is our this is ours
and a lot of it has our written words
associated with the photos so you can
find all of that over at
minimalism.com now ryan for our added
value this week since we've been talking
about emotional clutter one way that we
clutter our lives emotionally is when we
are emotionally unavailable
when we are unavailable for the people
that we love you know we might be there
but we aren't there there you know we're
somewhere else our mind is somewhere or
maybe we're stuck in our glowing screens
or we're thinking about something else
or someone else or some other
circumstance and quite often it's
making us miserable and also the people
around us feel like we're emotionally
unavailable yeah i got a mellow pop song
for you today this one is from caroline
policek it's called bunny is a writer
and you'll even notice there's a sample
in it i think it's a sample there's a
static in fact i bet the song is playing
right now in the background for you if
you're listening to the audio version of
the podcast if not if you're watching
the youtube version you can click right
up here and there's an awesome video
for uh for this song but you hear the
static even and that to me is the
emotional
unavailability
even within the song the song is memetic
of
of what we experience when someone is
not available for us
right there even though they're in front
of us and
the song the bunny a bunny rabbit is
sort of the metaphor right for our
emotions that we can't get a hold of
would you talk a lot about on the
maximal episode this week as well but in
the meantime check out caroline policek
this is bunny as a writer
by the way ryan we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are some ways we can help others work
through their emotional clutter i crave
a sense of control from growing up in a
chaotic household but now as an adult
it's costing me my relationships and
inner peace how do i keep my emotions
and trauma from holding me back i think
ryan secretly wrote that question in
and also is grief considered emotional
clutter or is it an essential part
of experiencing loss i actually wrote
all these questions
thank you
i do appreciate the questions from all
of our patrons and the rest of our
audience plus we got a million more
questions for dr susan david and the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast
this thursday visit patreon.com
the minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events and our
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalist on tik-tok instagram facebook
and twitter at the minimalist if you
want our podcast show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus alabama
podcast sean jordan no more professor
sean social jess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn if you live here today
with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
[Music]
because the opposite never works thanks
for being here yo we'll see you next
time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it